you know this you talk about
unappreciated Superstars you talk about
underappreciated team just jumping
nuggets nobody has believed in them all
season and they're here and listen
if the Miami Heat are able to win this
championship
it will be in my opinion the greatest
run
ever yeah for an underdog yep for an
underdog
no one has ever taken a tougher path to
get to this point than the Miami Heat
you know there's a lot of talk coming
into this series about Market size and
the franchises that aren't here the
nuggets are the best team in the west
throughout the season the Heats run will
get into a little more has been nothing
short of phenomenal and for casual fans
the casuals as the kids call them this
might be their first real exposure to
Nicola jokic you may just be the best
player on the planet Grant what are they
going to learn about this guy well Matt
you said it best first of all I had the
chance to cover the nuggets the first
two rounds and we were talking you know
in the back there just watching him play
in person the feel the passing he
doesn't beat you with the explosiveness
that we've seen from superstars in years
past but just a great understanding of
how to play the game very unselfish
has taken over at times but also can
beat you with the pass and really just a
treat kind of the modern day version of
a Tim Duncan a guy that doesn't
necessarily want all the attention
obviously his game is a little bit
different than Tim's but the personality
uh and you and Chuck said it best this
team look everyone was sort of counting
them out in the postseason okay they
were number one seed in the regular
season they're not going to get far it's
going to be Phoenix or Golden State or
or the Lakers and this team has a chip
on their shoulder and sort of the
feeling that they have something to
prove that you don't typically see from
a number one seed but jokic is a treat
to watch and we'll get a chance to watch
him here tonight for sure jokic comes in
as just a third player in NBA history to
reach the NBA Finals averaging a triple
double true three rounds what has
impressed you about this front I'm
actually anxious to watch him play in
person uh I'm actually happy that a big
man is now named the best player in the
league listen he plays with toys those
are confident and he plays the right way
us three Hall of Famers we can
appreciate that you know we see a lot of
guys that have a lot of talent don't
utilize their talent this guy right here
just goes out and he just outworks
everybody and it's a joy to watch I'm
always laughing Chuck that's a Chuck
this guy gets the easiest slowest 35 17
10 I've ever seen in my life and he's a
great player but again I'm anxious to
watch and see him you know to actually
watch him live there's nobody like him
and I'm not the Hall of Fame but I can
appreciate him as well that's why he's
got my MVP vote for three straight years
now as for the Nuggets obviously a
momentous occasion for this team the
last time the Nuggets reached this level
in a pro league was 1976 when they
played the final ABA finals lost in game
six to the then New York Knicks David
Thompson had 42 in the loss of Julius
Erving closed it out for 31 and 19. and
now the nuggets are
to finally reach the NBA Finals folks
around here have been waiting a long
long time for this well the thing that I
love about it is they did not count in
my opinion cheat and do the super team
thing it built through the draft through
trade this Joker dude was to stuck
around pick
it's incredible you know I mean I'm
sitting here thinking like first of all
it's got to be easy well I forget about
Steve Nash won two MVPs like is that any
other player who didn't got get two MVPs
who didn't go like in the first round or
something like that I mean I mean that's
crazy and amazing yeah well he's the
lowest drafted MVP already and he's got
two of them yeah I mean when nobody else
got two for sure but but I will tell you
this man they got to finish the journey
they got to finish the journey I think
they got a huge Advantage with the
Celtics losing because now they get the
home support they they came close to
losing at home right and so and I
actually think the game tonight is
really important because the Miami Heat
have been the underdog against all those
teams they always won the first game you
know because when you're on the dog
you say all the right things but we can
win blah blah blah blah but I think if
you go back and look at Milwaukee and
look at the Celtics who people assume
are going to beat the heat once you win
that first game everything's on the
table so I'm not saying the game is the
most win I think it's a really important
game for the Celtics in my opinion and
not only that Matt from experience like
when you see nine days of rest on a
piece of paper it looks beautiful yeah
but you know how much practice can you
do how much like nothing can simulate
what's about to happen here in a few
hours so uh hopefully the Denver Nuggets
don't come out Rusty or a little tired
you know I watched your press car where
they said they practice every day but
you know when you're in the finals you
practice but I don't want to twist my
ankle so you don't go ahead that's
always a question the rest thing and
then we looked it up terrific it's just
bogus because if they win if they play
well they're gonna say that refs are
good if they play bad they're gonna say
they were Rusty I will tell you this you
know Jack I want to say this about
firsthand experience
my biggest regret in my career
I feel soon because normally when I
played
at home I said let me get these other
guys going
and then I'll do my thing later I'll
never forgive myself when we played the
Bulls for the championship
my team never recovered game one they uh
you got to be really aggressive you got
to be really aggressive because to be
honest with you the lights were too
bright for us in game one because it's
different in fact you know you did it
more than all of us ain't nothing like
the NBA Finals so you got more press
conference you got more family and
friends so my advice to the Denver
Nugget especially joking Jamal yo man do
not wait because I tell people that's
one of my biggest regrets I was trying
to get other guys started before we
could get started they had pulled away
well you both think a great point in
Shaq you brought up that concern with
Denver obviously nine games look during
the game ones of all the games here in
the postseason Denver has been dominant
they have come out at home set the tone
they've scored 65 points in the first
half on 49 field goal shooting so they
they've tried to come out and knock
teams out Lakers in in the east in the
Western Conference Final had a great
second half in that game one but the
nine games are it'll be interesting to
see how they play because you said
they've been so dominant throughout the
regular season and the postseason at
home and in Miami they've been playing
they're in a rhythm they're in a groove
right now they've gone through a tough
Series so they could come out here yeah
and steal this game one which I said the
knife is really important again the rest
thing is maybe a little overblown to
your point oh teams with seven days of
rest before game one of the NBA finals
or more are still 13-8 about what you
would expect from any game ones with
that in mind which is a bigger Factor
tonight the relatively quick turnaround
for Miami and travel here or or the off
time in the early minutes
that makes a great point if you play
great the rest is good if you don't play
great it's a factor I've had both in my
experience we've had you know especially
for a guy like me having those four five
six days off and then you come in
everybody's just rusted
I don't know what it is I can't explain
it so to answer your question I think
Denver needs to come out and make a
statement you know everybody's already
picking them to win you know they have a
really big advantage in the middle they
need to take it back there so you know
Joker and Jamal and the guy all the
quarterbacks you got to take away the
home killer man you got to put these
guys away because it seems like Miami
Miami Heat if you give them a room
if you give them room they were always
finding a way to win absolutely both
teams have won all their game ones so
far in this one to the NBA finals
clearly